what up what's going on
did we asked people to subscribe and
unsubscribe to network I don't think it
worked we got a bunch of videos people
doing it thank you for doing it in my
opinion that experiment doesn't like it
doesn't move the needle too much I don't
I don't know if that technique is a big
technique let's answer five guys keeps
growing organically but we didn't see a
spike because we asked people to do it
let's answer all their questions don't
answer them today or I think next step
Thursday because I didn't have I got a
lot of all yeah the problem and I
apologize to people who send me things
on Instagram I don't check that ever oh
yeah you know there's two inboxes on
Instagram Facebook does that with her so
I didn't know that that was even a thing
and I had all these nice people sending
me reviews you find like a year later
yeah I didn't know that so apologies I
listened back to one of the episodes
which is a most uncomfortable thing you
can i've not listen to one ever yeah and
I don't blame you I listen back and you
know you were saying you're very
self-conscious now because we do the
video and that's how I am about the
audio because I listen to it and I'm
like what the [__] is wrong with me on
my talking biz fast why am i breathing
like that no I think you have a got you
got actually have a great voice I think
you have good cadence and someone at on
the meetups asked me he goes do you guys
cut out silence and I was like on the
audio we do but you do you Shawn does
that yeah oh I thought we didn't and he
was like you guys are talking so fast
yeah so he cuts out Ohm's Oz or big
repetitions like if I say the same thing
two different ways for no reason and
then I think he cuts a little bit of a
gap between us when he doesn't like it
he's like a perfection I told him not to
do it cuz it takes him like six hours oh
yeah every time he's like makes a
difference and I was like I don't know
if this mix [__] makes a difference I
got confidence from it okay
alright well if he's gonna justify it
now that's crazy I just thought we were
talking fast like we do talk fast but
it's the in-between where he speeds it
up and then he cuts out any like
extraneous [__] people like it you
know I also got tons of compliments from
Stu a few episodes back people liked him
people like Stu yeah high approval
rating people like he doesn't have to
drop out of the presidential race like
everybody else all right what do we got
today
a presidential did you want to talk
about Bernie is that your first thing I
have a thing up there but I didn't
research enough but I'll talk about it
just quickly so a bunch of people on
Twitter were freaking out because
Bernie's proposing this tax on vested
shares that you haven't actually cash to
him yet
okay and tech people were like okay
there goes the startup scene like well
you know if you're on vested shares that
they haven't actually received the prop
like this company is not liquid and so
there are some nuances like it's written
here it's taxed on non qualified stock
options of at least a hundred thousand
you know if you have over a hundred
thousand and stock stock options that
are vested and your and employees making
at least a hundred thirty K so it's not
everybody and it's not all types of
things so it's not RS use its ISO as I
believe okay so I'm not an expert in
this stuff at all and I'm not an expert
in politics I know what I believe but I
don't know the technical Depot well
let's agree to talk out of our ass for
so I'm not gonna talk about that
actually but here's what I am going to
talk about is starting a company and how
it worked with us in this wool a lot
because I do know that a lot of people
think like oh the rich are doing this
they don't understand things so when we
started the hustle I saved up twenty
five thousand dollars to start it with
that twenty five thousand dollars I made
sixty grand in profit in six weeks which
is pretty good and the first year in
business was roughly three hundred
eighty thousand dollars in revenue and
most of it was profit because I paid
myself we were I think we were an LLC I
withdrew $2,000 a month in salary salary
and that's why I paid my bills my rent
was cheap very cheap hundreds of
hundreds of dollars a month and I lived
off $1,200 beyond that beyond that it
was very I lived very very very frugally
and then we decided to raise a little
bit of money I raised I think three
hundred thousand dollars from people at
a three and a half million dollar
valuation you had to change from being
an LLC at this point right yep changed
an S corp I think it was an escort
probably C course I don't remember see
this is I'm not an expert in this yeah
you want to be a c-corp if you're gonna
take investment that's just like you
don't have to study all the differences
between them but if you're gonna take
like traditional investment they're
gonna want you to be a c-corp so we
converted it costs five grand to do that
at this point we probably had half
a million dollars in the mmm $300,000 in
the bank account
I don't remember between 300 and 500
thousand by the end of our first year
and we raised money at a three and a
half million dollar valuation and then
once we started doing stock options and
stuff like that we signed up to Carta
and they gave us a let's take all the
409 a yep
where we got so that for nine a just
values your company at some numbers yeah
you guys had revenue so they probably
took some standard before they valued us
and you want it to be low at this stage
yeah so they valued us in the millions
of dollars of range I don't remember it
could have been three and a half it
could have been six I don't remember the
number whenever these types of
businesses are that's what they've done
you want it to be low because that's
what your share price is that's what
your stock options are going to be if
you're an employee you want to get in at
the sort of low valuation so when it
sells at a high valuation you get this
sort of increase in value but if they if
the 409a comes back high then you're not
gonna get you know as much of a lift on
your share and so at this point our 409
a is many tens of millions which is nice
that's cool we have a valuable business
but when we started it was single-digit
millions which was still a lot I was 24
at the time I said I start with $25,000
and I was taking $2,000 a month I was
not saving any money right okay I'm not
complaining because it worked out but so
on paper I was a millionaire multiple
millionaire if I had to pay I think
there I forget what this I don't want to
like act like I know I'm talking about I
let's say if I if I had to pay 20
percent in taxes on that multiple
millions of dollars you wouldn't have I
literally wouldn't have had any money to
do it right even if I wanted to withdraw
money from our business account I would
have had to lay people off or right I'd
like so when people say such certain
people are hoarding money or something
like that
a lot of times it's not true and I have
a lot of founder friends that have
businesses that are on paper worth
hundreds of millions of dollars right
and they have tens of thousands of
dollars saved that's a bank account yeah
so they're not like RIT yeah I think
people need to and this also happens if
you're an employee you leave a company
you usually have what they call an
exercise when
which might be 30 days 60 days 90 days I
think that I think the normal 90 days so
that gives you three months to come up
with the money to buy your options or
you lose them yeah and a lot of people
don't have that money cuz like you know
they leave one company it's a startup
and now their shares are worth 80 grand
or 180 grand and they need to go they
want to go to a different job and now
that you need to come up with an 80 or
180 grand to buy out their options
that's not still a guarantee that that
money's coming back and often people
don't have that money sitting in the
bank so they'll forfeit their options
which is a true bummer some companies
are being cool about it Pinterest a
couple others I don't remember movie
stripe they increase their exercise
window to seven years or six years so
they're like look we know this practice
a little bit crazy it's hard to come up
with that cash and you worked here you
earned your shares so we're not gonna
try to take those back you have the
longer window because we might be
private for longer which is kind of a
cool trend so when I dub company should
do that my w2 income so at this point I
make money in eight or ten different
ways I got loads of things that just it
just has added up over time and that's
great and I still pay myself a salary I
pay myself not that much I'm not the
highest paid person here yeah and I but
my w2 salary we're gonna be four years
old I've been working on this as a
project since 2014 we're gonna be four
years old officially in April I next
month I my w2 salary and year one I
think was $24,000 year to maybe 36 and
then year three then I started going
higher right because the business was
established yeah but my w2 income
historically has been low right quite
low and so when I saw this and I saw
people getting mad at rich people I'm
like I bet people thought I was rich
yeah and you wouldn't have qualified for
this because it says you have to be
making at least a hundred 30k but like
what if I three years a tax on my stock
now it would be painful [__] hard
yeah you'd be in a really tough spot so
you know Bernie I like Bernie but this
is a little bit crazy this will really
screw up the way the startup ecosystem
works but it can also adapt I'm not even
gonna take a stand if I think it's crazy
I just didn't giving a perspective of my
business and that and and I think I I
now I think I have a lot more cash than
even most people who have companies that
are huge what's your biggest regret in
the way you setup or organized or
structured the company I wish I wouldn't
have raised money and I would have just
owned it all and why is that cuz I would
be greedy or and richer you didn't end
up needing that capital it's hard to say
because it worked it worked if I wanted
to start fresh again I would have been
able to do it I can start now what about
advice a lot of people think oh this
person is so successful right you raise
money from a bunch of cool smart
successful people either in media or not
in media yeah so that was helpful was
that truly like said did you get your
sort of values worth on the advice
component yes I'm not sure that that
typically plays out that way but I think
yeah it works okay so look our network
it's so [__] powerful me and you our
network is so powerful I have I think 35
investors ranging from Tim Ferriss the
founders of nerd wallet which is who
knows what that's worth billions of
dollars the founder of the Chive
founders a bleacher report
who else just look it up a lot of people
and I text them I just pranks them I'll
say you get a lot out of it I'll tell
you two things that you do that gets a
lot first your investor updates which
you send usually saying more frequently
now I said quarterly but before I for
monthly right 36 months I send up every
single month every single month and the
it was so well organized it was
basically like hey here's all the key
metrics you don't beat around the bush
it's like this how much cash we got in
the bank that's how much we made this
month there's how much the email list
grew this is how much our open rate was
boom that's number one number two and
how was your second sort of the way that
I set up as I go numbers I go just
here's the numbers there's no
interpretation right all right let's get
into it numbers boom okay then I go and
then I do things that are going well
things are not going well I need your
help
yeah yes or no yeah it was great and you
sent that too so you did the work to
keep them engaged and stay top of mind
do not under under underestimate this if
you're doing your business if there's
people who are willing to help you out
you got to find a way to stay top of
mind and and part of it is you you share
frequent updates and this
very good sign if you're an investor if
you're one of your companies stop
sending their updates for a bit that
company is about to die or they're on
their way to dying and they go into a
shell and Paul Graham has this great
post which is just like as an investor
when you see that you know it's time to
go check in and as a founder ironically
that's when you need to help the most
yeah so don't go quiet when you need the
help the most that's when you need to be
talking and asking and maybe you
actually won't die if you if you could
keep that going what other mistakes have
we made so I always regretted the I
think that the the normal way that
people give out equity is a little too
founder greedy so I wish I given more
equity to my team and so like you know
basically I wish I just negotiated it
better between what do I get what are
the investors get and what does my team
get I think it was imbalanced I think
some of what the investors got the team
should have got some of what I had the
team should have got because really like
the people who are there as person four
or five six really they're taken just as
much risk as you are in a way like they
were there when it wasn't obvious that
this is gonna work and so for the
all-stars I wish I had given more and
next time my next company I'll do just
that I will do you make sure that cool
four or five people I'll make sure it's
not like like typically in a comedy in
the pool be so I don't know exactly what
the pool will be but let's say so let's
go what's typical so typical company
eighteen two co-founders you start 50/50
you're gonna raise some money they might
end up taking 25 to 30% of the company
depending on how it goes let's call it
25% and so you know as the founders you
you've diluted down you're at I don't
know my maths bad but let's say you're
both at what is that 30 something 35
percent each now and and so you you know
that's where you're at and then your
team the option pool they typically say
is like 10 to 15% is your sort of option
pool yeah so the first few employees
might have like you know the key person
might get like one two three percent and
then everybody else is below that is
below one percent essentially and I just
think that's like a pretty hard skew so
I would try to get multiple people in
these sort of one one to four percent
range I would try to have like my core
my core team all be in the over one
percent
for sure and whether that means I take
the haircut or investors take the
haircut that's what I would do if it's a
tech company I think this is very
different if you're not a high-growth
tech company if you're out in San
Francisco again though I'd started
wherever I live and so if I want to live
here yeah I started here if I wanted to
live somewhere else I started somewhere
else now you can start it definitely
anywhere so it's just about your
preferences I if I was gonna start again
another thing that I would do is I would
go and get a job somewhere and just make
like when I started I hadn't I didn't I
was always self-employed mostly I wish I
would have worked somewhere maybe for a
little while before you did it or you
mean as I do something as a side hustle
before you just get the experience yeah
I think it would've been nice and it
saved money that's interesting I
wouldn't have thought you'd say that I
think it would be helpful to understand
how things I think if you did it for
three months you'd be like okay I'm done
it all worked out you want to talk about
some stuff yeah let's try out some ideas
okay
run the world I'll start there so cool
perfect timing perfect timing so these
guys been working on this obviously
before this - I think female founders
and what this is is it's a digital
conference so especially with
coronavirus and you've had major major
conferences shutting down so Facebook's
f8 conference done I only have canceled
I believe GDC is done you know like I
predict South by Southwest but this
episode will air in a couple days I bet
you they're gonna cancel yeah so tons of
these conferences are closing and I've
only this is a great experiment because
I've always wondered why aren't there
more digital conferences now we built a
product called blab that was sort of
like this people used it this way a
bunch of podcasters through a conference
on our platform and I just thought hey
this is cool because you could be remote
you can be anywhere in the world you can
attend this thing and what does a
conference have it has speakers cool you
can stream that online no problem it has
like exhibitors cool you could do that
online if you wanted to and it has the
networking and that's a little bit
harder to do online but you could do
that as well it's missing the biggest
component though which is what
serendipity yeah you have to engineer
that serendipity into the product that's
the biggest part these guys claim that
they sort of have recreated all of that
I don't know I haven't used it yet but
the cool thing is we're now gonna find
out because with all these
conferences canceling run the world is
taking advantage and they're going to
all the conference's they're saying hey
hosted on our platform we make this
really easy for you they have a cool
model where basically it's no money in
they just take 25% of the ticket sales
whose computer is up here
can you Google run the world oh yeah
pull pull it up and so they've raised a
bunch of money from andreessen horowitz
a lot of money announced it and Henry
just Google about the world and the
Beyonce song came up my friend had a
company called little things which is
the is that another song it's what's the
boy band with Harry Styles though oh
it's a what are they called five yeah
run the world today run the world dot
today is the URL so live events
worldwide anyways I think this is cool
and we're gonna find out if this is like
they've been dealt the best hand for
their product right now and we'll see if
they can pull this off that's
interesting do you think that like I
think we should do one of these for the
listeners like just like you do the New
York Meetup
I think we should just try just to take
this for a test drive I think we should
just do an impromptu one and hang out
with people get let everyone meet each
other I'm down I okay if we had to make
predictions if this is gonna work so I
would say the safe bet
the safe bets always know the safe spots
always know okay but if you had a
hundred million dollars would you invest
two million into this business I don't
know who these people are and I haven't
played with the products that's the
caveat let's say I've met the people and
I played with the product and I felt
like they did the thing you said which
is it wasn't just a live stream of
content or a chatroom like there was
some way to engineer the serendipity of
a network of the networking in a
conference or the discovery of new
products right like so if I felt like
they did something different besides
just a teleconference like livestream
then I would buy in but I got to feel
the magic that's a stock photo so
there's a Henry's pulling up a photo
right now of a mug that says hustle we
use that photo that's Henry was writing
up a cease-and-desist like during the
podcast that's great okay run the world
internet conferences you're in or out I
am going to say
51% in okay alright we'll take it so
well here's old dude by the time this
airs I'm gonna have setup to run the
world conference the link to it is gonna
be in the show notes and we will figure
it out so go in the show notes right now
if you're listening to this well let and
get a ticket to attend our conference
and we'll try this out well and then
we'll let everyone decide is this cool
or is this like one of those ideas that
sounds good in theory but it misses the
magic and never works uh Henry go to
godaddy.com real quick pick a URL and
we'll send them to that URL as well I'm
gonna hate going with show notes
okay either way we could just put it on
our my first million podcast my first
million Dom my first million podcast
calm okay
my first million podcast calm it will be
a redirect to that you wanna charge for
it yeah ticket will be whatever I don't
know pick a number
okay we'll make it cheap twenty five
twenty bucks
and what will be is what will it be
we'll invite our friends so we'll invite
some of the people that we think are the
most interesting we will do a talk on
hey how do we build you know well we'll
get will do the things you do in the
conference right so a couple speakers up
fireside chat and then networking where
people can meet each other okay and
we'll limit it to 100 people yeah okay
100 people that some amount of money my
first million podcast com yeah you go
try it out all right tweet what else we
got on the on the agenda oh I have one
scroll down you want to talk about some
book club stuff yeah okay so you sort
out more use for this is hilarious one
long-running
Google Doc with just bullet points for
every possible thing we might talk about
yeah it's great okay so we were gonna
talk I was gonna talk about this a few
weeks ago okay so um when I moved to San
Francisco I started a book club called
the anti MBA and I did it because I
didn't go to an an elite Ivy League
school but I was always envious of those
people because when I moved here I
didn't know a single soul and I felt I
always like stereotypes people I was
like tall beautiful white teeth with
Patagonia's and they had like lovely
networks don't you saw all around yeah
just like these like rich white people
who that's all I was like right
that's how I imagined it and it kind of
was that and I was always envious of
that so what I did was I create a book
club meeting where we would meet every
week and we would read one book a month
and I would convince an expert how did
you convince people to join this where'd
you throw it up a cold email guy I just
learned how to cold email people and I I
did it online so each week we would have
30 people show up and I probably had an
email list of 5,000 people who would I
was not in person this is all online 30
people in person see Ava yeah a lot of
my best friends I met this way 30 people
my friend had an office and let me use
it and we would just meet up and I would
and I would read a week ahead of time
and just make notes and lead discussion
and sometimes do we'd have an expert
okay and then I would send show notes or
meeting notes to the list and people
loved it
I made close to no money off of it or I
don't think I made any money off it I
just did it for fun and it was very
success successful and a lot of people
said that we should make it a thing I
think it's a stupid I thought it was a
stupid idea but book clubs are actually
kind of interesting so there's this
business called Book of the Month Club
it was started and I believe it was
started in the 1930s at this point it's
owned by it was owned by Bertelsmann
which is a large publisher a
multibillion-dollar publisher and then
recently a private individual bought it
for single-digit millions of dollars in
in the 40s 50s and 60s this was massive
I mean it was millions of people paid
for so it was quite a large business
hundreds of millions of dollars probably
in the 60s and 70s it's gone away once
Amazon came around a guy bought it a
couple years ago and it's quite large
still and what they do is scroll down a
little bit this is 90 million users what
the hell
no that's Goodreads oh that's good
region so book at the Month Club now has
a hundred thousand active paying
customers Wow which means they're in the
revenue range of ten to fifteen million
a year in recurring revenue and they the
founder said in an interview he want his
goal is to grow 5x a year for for the
next year not consistently I don't know
if that's I think that's bogus
but Book of the Month is kind of an
interesting thing I suspect I've always
thought that it would would not work
now my opinion has changed so Goodreads
has a hundred million users there's this
thing called Wattpad have you heard of
Wattpad I've heard of it yeah Wattpad a
lot of people don't know about it
Wattpad it's owned by a guy in Canada
and they have 400 employees it's a
multiple hundred million dollar a year
business I believe they it's a book club
for it's not a book club it's more write
on it you you write original stories
yeah but it's their categories roman
middle middle america romance novels so
if you're a 40 year old woman you
probably have heard a lot pad understand
that's the most popular category or yeah
buddy much all they do oh really okay
it's basically for women who it's like
men do video porn romance novels is
woman porn basically and so huge
business and now I'm quite bullish now
on these book clubs yeah Reese
Witherspoon has a book club my wife uses
it my sister you so many people have you
heard of this no sunshine some [__]
thing
Oprah had hers but hers wasn't on paid
membership but this is really smart like
what you're describing I'm like oh this
is good I think you gotta have probably
not gotta have but it's advantageous
here to have a brand like a Reese
Witherspoon or whoever Jennifer Aniston
or Gwyneth Paltrow or whoever or like
the hustle could do a book club you
could do a book club like I think that
you have to have a bit of cachet to
organize people around to get the energy
going that initial energy so here's one
angle you buy the rights to the book
which is expensive yeah why would you do
that well because I think the margins
and books are quite small I've talked to
Tim Ferriss about this he told me that
he earns I he didn't say that he didn't
tell me this but he told me I mean I
think he does about a million a month in
revenue off his podcast and he told me
that he this what he did tell me he has
made 10 times more money off the podcast
and all of his books combined right so I
I don't think people get paid a lot of
money for books March's it might be a
cheap asset you're saying yeah I think
it's quite cheap so I would one-up my
goal would be to buy the rights for the
book and make it popular you know who
have you heard of um there's this
company that owns the company that owns
Proactiv
it's called I know what you're talking
about it's the skin care it's a direct
marketing
they the guy who owns it it's a quite
large business he got his start because
he bought the rights to thinking Grow
Rich oh really and he helped make it
popular again oh wow
through infomercials so that's what I
would do is I would want to buy the
rights to all the books and there's
another company called Mentor box that
does this and Tai Lopez is one of the
owners so it's incredibly scamming I
mean like you sign up for like $20 and
then it's rolls into like a 400 month
thing it's like [__] stupid but book
clubs are super interesting to me so
would you do this like if you were gonna
do this now how would you attack it what
would you do so you buy the rights that
you buy the rights if I wanted to
bootstrap it no you can't how would you
do it so what I would do is I would look
at what you've I know me please vinyl me
please is my friend's business it's a
probably a couple million bucks a month
subscription things so what you do is
you give them $50 a month
and they send you a vinyl once a month
right and so I would do that but for a
particular type of category so what I
would do is I would create a Facebook
group and I would say it's $30 or $50 a
month and we're gonna read one book a
month I'm gonna get one expert to come
and talk about the book each week or
each month we're gonna do it in a
Facebook group and I'm gonna send you
notes about the home and what category
do you think you choose would you do the
romance novel or would you do business
or would you do so well just because I
have such a networking business that I
could just crush it off the bass yeah
but romance novels I know this from
experience cuz I've invested in these
types of things romance novels have to
have the highest liquidity PS and people
consume them the most right so I like
voracious readers 5 5 times the number
of romance category is probably one of
the most it's probably the most popular
category on Kindle yeah I bet you it is
so okay
personally I would start here but if I
even slightly was interested in romance
novels I would and I like what this guy
did buying the rights to the Book of the
Month Club you know some a popular asset
that's sort of decayed over the last
thirty years and see if you can
revitalize it on the cheap there's
interesting businesses there's so many
books that I love that are written in
the 60s and 70s and you try to buy them
on Amazon and there are hundreds of
dollars because they've just been
forgotten and they don't reprint them
right I just try to buy a book the other
day for that someone mentioned it on
Twitter and it was $900
what book it was so I just tweeted about
Agora that's the scammy
company which we can talk about if we
want but the it was all about
copywriting was 900 bucks Wow okay yeah
let's talk about Agora okay you want to
hear about it
okay so Agora is is what it's a b2b paid
newsletter company yeah as absurd
revenue go to my Twitter account
okay so here's another interesting
company I know this because I'm in this
world and it's directly related to us
yeah just yeah that's sampar yeah
whatever that's fine okay so agora crazy
interesting background so Agora was
started by this guy named Bill Bonner in
the 1970s he was a publisher he had a
magazine about money and investing and
things like that and then he decided to
start changing how we did his marketing
and he created a newsletter that would
became quite popular at this point it
you'll see it's the most popular one no
up higher at this point they make it's
rumored to be one and a half to two
billion dollars a year and the way that
they do this there it is they own 20 to
40 different newsletter publishers and
what they do is is they buy a ton of
traffic to their funnels their marketing
funnels and right off the bat they'll
sell you a $50 product right and once
you buy that $50 product they now have a
large database an email list of
qualified buyers who are interested in a
particular topic and they typically lose
money on this first purchase so let's
say that they have a book that's 50
bucks they'll spend up to two hundred
dollars to acquire you meaning they'll
buy 10 ads and they'll lose money on you
but they'll make it up because on that
they call a back end on the back end
they sell you a $2,000 paid newsletter
and this company in particular they even
sell supplements and [__] now some
people think that they some people love
them and when you own 20 or 40 different
brands you're gonna have some
legitimately great products right so
what's their best product money map
press.com
or yeah money map press so this is for
hedge funds for a financial trader no
yeah
some financial traders they're their
typical audience is white men between 50
and 70 who's who who are conservative
and believe it like the government's
gonna come and like take your money I
mean that goes like so I sign up some of
their funnels and there was [__] like if
you go to Breitbart comm you'll see an
ad that says like Nancy Pelosi's coming
for your money and things like that and
you sign takes you through one of the
Agora and it's a five dollar book and
then yeah and then you'll go through
these funnels if now let's just get rid
of the whole unethical part because you
can learn from everyone who cares if
it's unethical or ethical it's
fascinating regardless and you could
learn from it what they're experts at is
copywriting and everyone in Silicon
Valley not everyone but you know you get
the point it's all about design its kind
of look good it's gonna be aesthetic
their websites are a blank page with
text right not just text but like
[__] 5,000 words in a buy now button
at the very bottom it's quite
fascinating that is fascinating and I
think you're you know you know that
Peter teal quote where it's like what's
something you believe to be true that
for you would agree with you on yeah I
feel like you know you might have many
but one of them would be copywriting
over design any day copywriting over
design 100% and most people I remember
when I learned the word copywriting so
say what is it what is copy why does
everyone keep saying this and like I
literally was at work and people like
hey can you give me some copy as a
coffee what she just asked me go get a
coffee for her like I had no idea what
the [__] she was talking about and and
then I sort of learned Oh copy means
text that's gonna come on the website
and then through you I realized hey wait
a minute the text that's on your website
is essentially your sales man and sales
gives you the money I probably learn how
to do this
how did I waiting deep on it it's the
most important skill you can learn
because I've spent years learning it if
you just give me a blank page I will I
will make money till I die right I will
always have a job because I could do
that now what I could do is do really
unethical [__] and scam a lot of people
really easily but if you know how to
copyright do you know how to persuade
via the written word yeah I would say
persuasion is the most important skill
whether it's through the written word
verbally you
I don't know if there's some of you have
a copyright variation copywriting just
the form in which you learn it now the
way that I describe it is if you're a
good copywriter you understand what
motivates people and if you understand
what motivates people you can create
products that they'll want that will
appeal to people yeah and then if you
are cut that is that's the when you do
copywriting you just learn what
motivates people and then you just
happen to use the written word to write
communicate yeah when when you mentioned
the boron letters and then I just went
deep on that that was like my foray into
this so we'll do a whole section on did
you read the copy right yes and then I
started like doing all the things in it
because I got obsessed
so the boron letters if anyone's curious
Gary Halbert is his name he's dead now
he died of a heart attack she kind of
hard to find it's hard to find but
there's one link and if you get to it's
like chapter one two three nineteen or
whatever it's this copywriter who's one
of the best copy writers of all time and
what he would do is he was such a good
copywriter that he kind of turned into a
crook and so he would write these sales
letters to buy like encyclopedias or and
buy like [__] anything just [__] so
the boron letters are the way it stars
it's like he's writing to his son he's
in jail he's in jail writing to his son
and he doesn't start off by being like
here's how you copy right he's just
writing to his son and it's one by one
and each one's a teaser every sentence
teases the next sentence and every
letter teases the next letter and then
by the time you get twenty deep you're
like this guy's a master it is awesome
so read that alright what do you guys
Sean a couple others okay so here's an
idea so I was talking to my cousin and
we were talking about like one of my
cousin's he's young he goes on dates
uses the apps boom boom boom and then
like our aunts and uncles are always
like oh my God look at him he's just
swiping left and right he goes on dates
it's like really foreign concept to them
and so that was one data point okay just
kind of notice wow my aunts and uncles
they really don't get it when it comes
to this online dating thing data point -
I'm watching the debate and it was I
watched so much [__] online that when I
watched traditional TV first of all it's
so slow and secondly I start to see the
commercials and I'm like oh this is
what's being advertised to mainstream
America like cars it's very fascinating
so like Noom was on there which is like
the diet like nutrition plan thing they
do really really well you know I'm
we should break them down later they
advertise but the other one was some it
was the this gray-haired woman comes on
the on the screen and she's like Oh
online dating where do I start and then
it's like well open up your browser type
wwm to RL it's like and then start
clicking around like that was literally
that was the ad was like how do I even
get started as like here's how you get
started online dating I remember the
name oh come on it wasn't like a match
or I'd never heard of it before so I
started thinking and I was like you know
there's so many people that are sort of
in my sort of extended family and
whatnot that are divorced and they're
alone and so I was thinking about them I
was like you know it'd be great if they
found someone but the reality is they
don't do a lot of online dating because
it's so scary in foreign and it's not
the online part that's scary it's the
expectation that you then need to go
meet somebody and so like let's take my
uncle for example my uncle's I don't
know 65 years old he is divorced he gets
lonely his kids are all grown up
everyone left the house and you know he
doesn't want to actually like it'd be
great if he met somebody who was awesome
and they could just like be companions
for there stood life but he's sort of
like dude I don't want to get out there
like last time I went on a date was 40
years ago like I think I'm just out of
the game it's easier to be lonely than
it is to put yourself out there so
anyways long preamble for the idea the
idea is a service that's for older
people let's make it just 50 and up as a
rule and it's called just talking and
the expectation is you're gonna go out
here with other people who are like you
are sort of single might be alone
looking for companionship but it's just
talking you can't meet it's not their
real names it's nothing it's just
somebody you could log onto the computer
and just talk to either through audio or
text and you could talk to them
continuously or you could switch and
pick somebody else and talk to them but
it's just companionship as a service for
and it's not dating you're not gonna
start going out with this person you're
not trying to get remarried
you're just getting the reps in you just
don't want to be lonely at home anymore
and honestly you can have a virtual
relationship you know through this and
it's because I was also watching love is
blind so and I was like dude somebody
should make an app that's just this now
off the back of the idea and so anyways
these are sort of some ideas what do you
learn about it by I love it I love it
whitter that's a winner what I would do
is I would go
and do research on the sex hotlines that
used to exist that probably don't exist
anymore right and I would want to learn
how they work I bet they crushed so I'll
shout out something like tangentially
related so sex hotline related but
obvious answer P so wonder sex that
killed it then there's one startup out
here in San Francisco called Papa have
you heard of this Papa yeah Papa is
grandkids as a service so it's just
young people but you that will just come
over to your grandparents house and just
do stuff for them and like talk to them
but like also do their laundry and like
take out that trash I don't know if
they're doing well or not they just
launched it raised a bunch of money and
because there's this huge aging
population of the baby boomers and so
there's this wealth of opportunities
that are for the this the largest
generation of people ever in America is
now getting old and I forgot this woman
was calling it the the the gray new
world and you know for gray hair so
she's like you know the gray new world
opens up all these possibilities so one
is Papa which is gang kids as a service
one is honor because I know honor
there's a huge shortage of caretakers
for for the elderly and so honor is a on
demand caretaker platform that you know
track here are you going with caring for
old people or helping people get laid
I'm talking about just talking that's my
idea but I was just tangentially saying
there's some other businesses that are
trying to help this population here what
do they do
never heard of that no jack invested in
it and he says it's going well it's
called a relationship hero relationship
hero calm and they teach you how to do
online dating okay
just coaching for all my dating go can
you go to pull that out that's how it
started as it might be a little bit
different for you this would be for
younger people though maybe for whoever
I think if you did just talking and you
ran a bunch of Facebook ads you could
get a lot of people to pay to be a part
of a community of people where they can
have these online relationships aisle
expectation is you do not go offline I
think it's great no I think it's great
is because the way the way that you're
positioning it is is as a marketplace
those are notoriously hard to make but
once you have them they're great yeah
the reason why I like this is you can
kind of fake it at first yeah so you can
just hire people you can have some
operators yeah better than providing
that companion I think it's a great idea
you could seed the marketplace
with the operators yeah I think it's
awesome we talked about only fans yeah
that's training today on Twitter is it
yeah worldwide because of what some
strikes it got down I didn't get the
joke I clicked on it and try to
understand it and I didn't right I
didn't get it
one out of three Twitter trends yeah
yeah it was a top only fans which we
talked about only fans great business
but I love just talking I think it I
think that's a great idea thank you
thank you for thank you very much
no I think that's that's a winner all
right I have a question for you now so
before last week I think maybe was when
I was with Stu but I I shared this
anecdote or this this sort of advice
which was if you're offered to see it on
a rocket ship
you know don't ask which seat just sit
down and buckle up and this is just
career advice which is if you're not
going to start your uncommon flack for
it did I yeah I thought people loved it
well but what was what was the criticism
based on it wasn't even controversial
just stuff like titles it was just
comments like people saying titles are
important how much you get paid is more
important things like that that's crazy
disagree hard disagree okay so anyways
the question was sort of that led to a
different question which is what are the
rocket ships of today and so somebody by
the way took that idea and made of
rocket ship newsletter for jobs or
whatever but beyond that I was just sort
of thinking just my thought experiment
what companies that today are worth 1 to
5 billion do I believe will be multi
hundred billion so what's it just as a
way of phrasing it simpler what five
billion dollar company today could
become a five hundred billion dollar
company in the future I say this because
we have friends who bought Facebook
secondary stock back in 2006 2007 when
Facebook was valued at over a billion
dollars and today Facebook's like
whatever five hundred billion dollar
company and that you know it was clear
it wasn't going to zero it was clear it
was a thing and the question but you
could have invested then and got a
phenomenal return and I have several
friends who did I had a friend Alex oh
no sorry Josh Buckley who's a good guy
founder and British guy yeah British guy
he's and so he he was telling me we were
just hanging out one day he's like yeah
I'm buying secondary stock of stripers
my
I can get and I was like what do you
mean like I'm not doing that why why are
you doing that I should do that and he
was like yeah I just think stripes a
great company and there's secondary
stock available and I'm just buying it
I'm like well what's the valuation it's
already like a two billion dollar
company he's like yeah but it's like
trips gonna be big
he's a guy thinks trips gonna be huge so
I'm just buying up secondary and now so
stripes Valley bound like 20 billion
dollars so he took essentially like a no
risk pet in my opinion and 10 next his
money on a private company that was
there was already a unicorn but wasn't
yet on the stock market it wasn't doing
like 10% a year you know that's a 10x
appreciation so long story short what
companies do you think have that
potential that are in the single-digit
billions today or less that you think
could be a Facebook Google Amazon of our
generation so a few years ago I answered
this question and I thought it was
Atlassian and I went in on that and it
worked okay tell me about that what you
mean it worked back then it was you just
look look go ahead and relook go to a
laughingstock you're busy today I
invested lasting in stock it's not like
I like yeah I'd let at last seen smoke
with an 8080 there it is yeah and then
go to all-time I bought at laughs max on
the far right I bought it when it when
it went public so what did they go up by
it's like a 3x already so I 3x my money
so I bought a glass Ian because I read
their annual report I was like oh these
guys are great their market caps now 35
billion yeah so I bought it right when
it went out so that worked so well what
do you think could get to the over a
hundred billion it's very hard to get
over a hundred billion how many
companies are worth over 100 billion
like very very few especially if you
think about tech companies so some of
the tech companies that made it Amazon
made it Google made it Microsoft made it
Facebook made it
uber did not quite make it yet but it's
given their Tesla made it like I think I
invested in Tesla when it was at about
this number five five to eight billion
oh really and now it's almost 100
billion and so like that's that's a big
lift of a company that it's out there
it's not a seed same startup you're
taking a bet on right it's a company
that's out there and the other way to
take the bet on it even if you're not an
investor is to go work at one of these
companies right so like Airbnb was a
good candidate
now it's valued too high to qualify for
this
everybody's like it I don't know 35
billion or something like that we'll see
it what happens with this but it's not
in a single digit billions anymore but
when we when we moved to San Francisco
we could have done that right when I
moved as happens you I had a job offer
at Airbnb when it was worth billion 1
billion maybe less I don't know there
was only knows less it was dozen 12
right so so let's just say was that a
billion which it wasn't but let's say it
was yeah I would have made 10 million
dollars it's 35 X so even if you had
just gotten a sort of standard stock
package which was like over four years
you're gonna get 200 grand made five or
ten million dollars yeah that's insane
and I got fired before I even showed up
to work so some other candidates that I
put up here flex port I think as a
candidate maybe you got some inside
Intel that sounded like a juicy maybe
well Ryan told me he thinks it's gonna
be massive or to go bankrupt which is
like how you gonna be when you that's
how you some other this was harder than
I thought I also tweeted this out so the
most popular answers I got was air table
and Carta and I pretty much disagree
with both of those I don't know I and I
asked these are smart people replying
and I was like Carter why Carter
we should get Carter response to this
podcast by the way yeah why are they not
I don't know you guys see a sponsor and
I'm gonna I don't give a [__] a bit
people sponsor I'm gonna tell you the
truth Carter
it's the best option out there but it
still needs a lot to improve right I use
it I give you guys five grand a year I'm
happy that I give you the money but it
can improve yeah so err table err table
it would have to basically replace Excel
in the corporate world for it to do this
otherwise it will not be a hundred
billion dollar company how about gust oh
gosh does a good one so I think there's
a lot that are in the sort of either HR
tech just you need to be a huge
spotlight just oh and rippling ya go so
rippling I think I would be 100 billion
is a high bar but yeah so other ones I
that I put up here so stripe but it's
past this point
so coinbase only if the big if bitcoin
actually becomes like a bitcoin actually
is the thing it becomes the global
reserve currency then well it doesn't
have the largest bitcoin sort of company
the large bitcoin brand would be i think
they become Bank of America can become
Wells Fargo yeah but I think Bitcoin has
to become that relevant for coinbase to
be yeah I buy that open door is another
one just because
residential real estate is so big so if
they actually have a working model they
could become a hundred billion dollar
company I don't buy that because what
because Zillow and Trulia aren't that
huge they don't do what these guys do
though Zillow and Trulia they sell leads
to brokers they're now trying to copy
opened doors and now they offer what
kokand are offers but open doors
literally buying and selling the houses
they're flipping houses at scale which
is pretty crazy what else this was tough
I know that's a lot but I put this on
here I wasn't gonna talk about it
initially but I'm like I want to bring
this up I want people to tell me what
I'm wrong about what companies I should
be considering in this but I think it's
a really important question because for
me I'm gonna go try to buy secondary
stock and all these company okay so I
don't and if you're working you should
go work at one of these companies a
hundred billion is that's impossible
I won't even I'm not gonna try to pick
that because like only like a few
hundred people or fewer a few hundred
businesses have ever probably done that
I don't know the number but that's
really hard to say but if I had to make
a prediction I do think that there will
be some new search engines and I also
think that some of the new chrome
replacements could be quite large so
brave is one of them what's another one
I'm placing the browser yeah anything
that are replacing browsers I think are
kind of cool and could potentially be
that big I think there's gonna be a lot
of browser I think if any company nails
a are they will they will be able to do
this but that's not ways away I believe
how about a zoosk Duke's self-driving
car company yeah yeah so that was the
other I I considered all the
self-driving car companies cuz I'm like
if if one of them becomes a success a
self a successful self-driving car
company the market leader will be worth
over a hundred billion it's just more
likely I believe is more likely to be
Tesla or one of the incumbents rather
they'll buy one of these companies
rather than that company independently
going from where it is today which is 1
billion two hundred billion how about
this what companies are public now that
could grow that much so I was talking to
Moyes the other day and we were looking
at stamps calm you know crazy
undervalued and the next day we were
like let's buy this the next day we
didn't buy in time it went up fifty
percent went up 50 percent
it was coincidental just I saw the
interesting stat over the last 10 years
if you're just brought bought the fang
companies at Facebook Amazon Apple
Google in the ten years it outperformed
all VCS or sorry it I'll perform even
this sort of top like expected returns
of venture capital so the public market
if you just bought the five most popular
tech stocks you did better as a twenty
twenty four percent IRR over ten years
okay well what what's public now that
could I don't [__] know that's a
great question it's that's hard you got
a really bet on industries what do you
got sports betting good that's a good
that's good and if the legislation keeps
opening up that's a good call
I would do sports betting I would bet on
that industry that's a great call okay
we ventured off into stock tips so I
want to get back because we don't know
[__] about the stock market
that's not our that's not our promise
let's tell them something else that we
find interesting what else you got you
want to do one more I'll mention one of
the cool company that's related to
stocks actually public comps calm so
public comps yeah he's just breaking
down s ones for companies which like a
lot of people like to do nowadays but
it's just a good you don't have to do
the research this guy does the research
for you and he publishes it I like it
let's do uh let's do let's wrap up with
made renovation you talked about this in
one of our very first podcast exactly so
one of the very first ones was like hey
I saw this ad I think this is awesome
idea what it is if you don't remember
because you're not a die-hard the what
it was is it's a turnkey bathroom
renovation so if you want your bath and
so the ad was just a dope looking
bathroom and it was like if you want
this bathroom it's like five grand and
you don't have to like because what
happens today you have to hire a
contractor you have to come up with the
vision board of what you want to be you
have to choose all these different
materials then he sources it and then it
turns out and then it's like that's a
one-off so they have like four designs
of bathrooms you just pick which one you
want you want the old Victorian
cool-looking one you want the modern one
or you want the middle-of-the-road one
yeah we said I wish barboursville and
here's the price and you just push the
button yes it's like actually some
barbers do this you go up on the
haircuts like three yeah I'll take the
number three large you know you know no
problem so that's what they're these
guys are doing for bathrooms I thought
that was really smart so it turns out
this
was not just like some random started
this is Roger Dickie was starting this
and he's a he started gigster he's done
some cool stuff in Silicon Valley before
so he's not a sort of Joker and they
raised 9 million bucks and they came out
of stealth and I was like I gave myself
a little pat on the back that's a good
one that's a good call
that's a pretty good call I still things
a very cool idea and I also think that
anybody could compete with them because
this will not be winner-take-all because
you have to be doing local renovations
look at that a city's they announced it
this week
good job yeah can I get myself a pat on
the back yeah
one of my first angel investments Lucy
Lucy nicotine calm I think I don't even
know what the URL is to be honest you
explain what it is people don't know
yeah so I invested it all your way all
your friends are buying Lucy [__] yeah
money the bag yeah hey so one of my
first angel investments I don't remember
when this was three years ago the
founder of Soylent Dave who's my friend
Dave ran town run ten he started this
thing and it was based it's basically a
Nicorette so it's right anyways
Nicorette nicotine gum and he told me
about it and i was like alright well
dave you started Soylent so you're
pretty smart you scaled that thing up
yeah I knew him well he's a good guy and
it's an it's a big market its nicotine
so I'm like okay well I mean this is
retentions gonna be good yeah I'm I'm a
nicotine user I like the gum I chew the
gum and I like those shoes Nicorette
yeah I like to my preferred lozenger so
I'll put them in my mouth okay and but
you don't smoke so you just do this just
like a team I like nicotine it's I don't
I don't smoke it's it's it's my that's
my vice and and it's a monthly
subscription yeah I was like yeah yeah
of course you'll [__] knock that one
out the park really smart and they just
raised a lot more money and so on paper
which is completely useless on papers
not gonna buy me a house or pay my rent
but the evaluation went up significantly
so I got a little my corner store guy
has it at the front by the register and
I said okay whatever is at the front by
the register
that's what's selling that's what
wait we'll make money it's it really I I
did I sent Dave a picture I was like no
[__]
Henry although the guy the guy I asked
him I said how well does this sell he's
like he's pretty good it's not Jules but
it's pretty good are the kids are buying
Nick Lucy oh [__] yeah yeah pay the
taxes on it money in the bag I I think
that's a 5 or 6 X so far I'm proud that
would be a good investment I like that
one that would be nice
I think we were one of the first folks
in on that one fucking-a I hope it works
and just for the while it is awesome I
it's totally luck so I'm not that much
credit but awesome
alright you want to talk about anything
else uh no I think we're good I think
we're good
let's sit the save it we're gonna do
another one in two days I got some other
stuff for that all right thank you give
us a review and share with your friends
yeah tell your friends so yeah